Russia has
sent tens of
thousands of new troops
to Ukraine's frontlines
over the last few months,
according to a senior U.S.
military official.
Meantime, Moscow's deadly, vulga
military known for its brutal ta
and refusal
to retreat,
has begun to encircle back
loot in the Donbas.
CNN's Ben Wedeman has more
from
Eli Worth.
Jones is a long way
from his hometown of Las Vegas,
A medic
he's delivering
supplies to residents
just a few hundred yards
from Russian lines in Beirut.
He does it because he can
young and trained for
this is what I do for a living.
We all stand.
There's a lot of people in need
And I don't like feeling so much
so happy to be here
and stay with the people who've
been stepped on.
Eli is with a group
called Frontline Medics,
and you can't get much more fron
in this
fellow medic
Kurt Eriksson from Norway
explains how they work.
We got a list of patients,
but we don't really know
what's wrong with them,
so we don't have any idea before
you see them.
And we do that assessment.
Our interview cut short by an in
Russian
at a slightly safer distance
from the fighting.
They park their mobile clinic
and treat who they can
Alexander says his feet on pain.
Can you ask him which foot it is
I kind of go
over both okay.
He lives in an unheated a partne
may be suffering from frostbite
as long as he is.
They'll take him to a hospital
outside Borehamwood,
and he couldn't leave a moment s
The Russian noose is tightening
slowly.
Russian forces are gaining groun
They're on the high ground behin
They're advancing from the north
and they're advancing from the s
Who
is yet to come, says British vol
soldier Daniel Burke.
You need to take a solid out to
and kind to try to do a big pinc
movement of armaments.
I don't think I'm trying so quit
but if I'm going to try
or post it for the fields,
I'll just close off
Yet residents stay on and volunt
of all stripes do what they can.
The Victoria Clinic is doing
the rounds, handing out food and
Are you a little nervous
with the situation here? Oh, loo
Are you serious?
No,
nerves of steel.
As the shelling goes on